well today we're going to talk a little
bit about openings I'm also going to
review quickly what I do with my last
class because it's just such an
important concept and in chess a lot of
times you got to learn something four or
five times till you really get it we are
going to talk about the quickest made in
chess and make sure that it doesn't
happen to us actually technically the
quickest checkmate in chest is the fools
mate but it almost never happens
anybody remind me what the fools mate is
Arjun excellent very good Arjun so this
is the fools mate when white plays f3
now you can start with g4 and it's
really funny because in my last class we
had a kid who I would say explain why g4
wasn't a good move in he immediately
said but my dad always plays that
against me but g4 is it's probably
better than playing f3 to be honest I
mean this movies even worse why just
this is probably one of the worst moves
I think this might yeah absolutely
probably the worst move you can start
the game with I believe that that is
true yeah why is f3 like just the worst
move you can start the game with Isabel
yes the one thing is that's horribly
weakening for the King there's another
thing that's a terrible about f3 that's
right that would be a checkmate but let
me put freeze this question a different
way f4 is not nearly as bad of a move as
f3 why do you think that is like f4 it's
not what I would recommend but it's not
nearly as bad because after f4 you can
continue developing at some point with
what Narita hmm right with one move how
could you continue developing here if
you were right and you would play that
for um what's your name
I I on day I end a ok I end a
excellent that is why this moves not
nearly as bad when you put your pawn on
f3 not only are you weakening your king
but you're also taking out the best
Square for our Knight right when we
start the chess game the one thing we're
pretty sure of is that we usually want
to move our knight to f3 and c3 why is
that why are we so sure of that AJ yes
because we want to attack the center and
there's not that many options for our
Knights or other option is h3 and that's
towards the side and if we put our
knight on so if we play something like e
4 and then play 92 that's not good
either because what is it black you lie
right the black stuff so this is almost
always putting our knight on f3 so
that's why f3 such a bad move okay but
anyway I just want to go over quickly
what I would I went over with the other
class because they had some because I
was I'm just always surprised by how
strong players can be and yet still fall
into what we call the four-move
checkmate so we want to really take that
out of the possible how many people play
the movie 4 raise your hand me too
how many people play something different
Tristan you play d4 is that what you
were saying earlier okay
d4 is a great move a lot of great
players play it and you like what do you
play okay so you play your pawn here or
something okay that's fine it's not a
bad move at all it's like when you're
starting out though a lot of times you
want to play more classical you want to
play just get the center but I don't
mind playing g3 so II for most of you
play that now it's black how many of you
play this move great alright this is
just a fantastic way to start the chess
game to play e5 against efore just both
of you are trying to get your pieces out
in Castle now if your opponent plays is
Bishop out at this moment what is the
first thing that
go through your mind Isabel that's right
so you're already thinking Isabel that
the Queen might come here and attack s7
and that would be mate and now that so
you can tell that they're going to do
that because when they put their Bishop
out first
that often means that especially if it's
a kid because if they didn't want to
checkmate you quickly on f7 instead of
bringing the bishop out first what do
you think they would do AJ yes Knight
where can you use test notation for me
exactly they would usually play this
move which is which is probably the best
move in the positions the most common
grandmasters are usually playing this
move why do you think grandmasters so
often develop their nights before they
develop their bishops so the reason the
Grandmaster is about nice before bishops
is simple because we just talked about
it the night we're almost positive where
we want it to go right you want it to go
to c3 or act 3 or f6 or c6 where as a
bishop it's not so clear we have a few
different options for this Bishop what
are some good options for this Bishop
laughs lon Charlie c4 is a good one do
you have any other ideas Tristan c4 is
good but sometimes it goes to another
square is about where else is it
sometimes go it doesn't usually go to d3
why does the bishop not usually go to d3
we're doing a lot of lot of work on
openings today I want you guys to play
even stronger moves in the opening are
Jen excellent blocks the depot and wise
had a problem you can't develop your
other bishop and you want to play with
all your pieces fantastic Arjen so
that's why I just rip d3 is usually not
played unless maybe this pawn is out
already then pointing the [ __ ] 1 d3
makes a lot more sense because then we
don't have to worry about that bishop so
Bishop d3 is really typical what other
move do we see a lot by the way black
usually defends this pawn right this
move at axis pawn so this one defends
one of them who do we see very often in
this position besides Bishop c4 Arjen
Bishop b5 we see a ton right so finally
it's
usually happening in this position but
in a lot of positions we see you move
that Eli mentioned earlier the so called
feein kettle you use that word Eli what
does the fee and kettle mean excellent
right and that's something that I you
know you sometimes have grandmaster
yasser sara Juan come in to teach
classes
anybody remember yasser from kids
classes fantastic well that's something
that yasser is really good at so when he
comes in ask him about the fan kettle
tell him i told you to ask about it so
when you put your pawn on g3 and you put
your bishop on g2 that's a fee and
kettle and that's another way to develop
in castle right it's a little bit more
rare why do we not like it that much in
this position it doesn't happen that
often in this opening with E 4 it
happens a lot in other openings but not
this one why is that anybody know why we
don't see white feein kettle in here
that often Tristan
time
well that's a great point like for
instance if we already had a pawn here
or something we can maybe in some
position play Bishop basics and stop you
from castling the only thing is that's
not going to be that effective because
we can block that idea was to move like
d3 at the right moment so I don't think
that's the reason the reason is that
rather when we have our bishop on apheon
cattle we usually want it to be a strong
bishop is this a strong bridge up
Charlie why not very good excellent you
mentioned two important things here
Charlie mentioned that a sea and cattle
wing is not his favorite thing because
it takes a little bit longer to castle
that is true that's why you see people
do it a lot when they play d4 c4 in the
first move like yes or Sarah one who I
mentioned earlier because in that
position the positions less open so it's
okay
if you wait a little bit longer to
castle but that's a very advanced
concept some of you are a little bit
more advanced here so I'm throwing that
out there
but the bigger reason which Charlie also
mentioned is that this pawn here stops
the bishop from having a lot of power
right so Bishop we want to have
diagonals just like we want to have our
rooks on nice open vials right so that's
the reason that we don't usually see
that move instead okay what really quick
though I did want to show you what I
showed the other kids so after Bishop c4
we talked about how like knight c6 white
might play something like Queen age five
what's the best way to defend here
what's the best way to defend here all
hands should be up because a lot of kids
are going to try this against you even
though you're strong enough um with the
guitar what's your name
Agastya Agastya hey no let a gusting
answer he had his hand up himself
well that's if it's White's move if it's
white to move you want to play Queen
takes pawn why is that so great
right it's a checkmate all right that's
not a bad mood check me to could boom
but if it's blacks move what's the best
way to stop that threat people try this
against you because they want to have a
quick win even if it's not the best way
to play in the opening they'll do it
anyway it's about what g6 why is that
your favorite move here
speaking of fianchetto is exactly and
then when the Queen comes to f3 hat
what's your best move here Caleb what
give me give me a piece before you or do
you want to play pawn tactics okay
Knight takes pawn when you say f6 and
you don't put a piece in front of it and
chest language that technically means
you want to move up on there does
everybody know that like if you're
watching grandmasters talk about chess
and you hear them say f6 it means pawn
to f6 so be careful because when Caleb
said f6 I know he meant Knight to f6 but
because I could tell by the way you were
looking at the board but and I know you
like to develop your chess pieces but
technically what you said meant F sex
right now why is Essex not a good move
AJ mm-hmm yeah you can pretty much
easily attack blacks position because
what can black not do once he's played
that set what can you no longer really
do even if he gets his pieces out Arjun
he can't move a knight to Essex and he
can't castle because if he even if
you've developed all his pieces he won't
be able to castle because of why it's
better yeah the bishop would be putting
you in check so that's a really bad
thing to do then to move this pawn
forward whereas the other idea that
Caleb really made Knight of 6
excellent move because let's say white
plays 92 or something
what will back to next tell me what
black does next charlie
actually I don't like Bishop c5 here and
again this is an advanced concept but
the reason I don't like Bishop c5 is
because you've already played this move
g6 and once you've played g6 you have
what we call holes around your King that
means there are squares that are easy
for way to occupy for instance say I
just played my pawn here now and then
you Castle or let's say you don't Castle
let's say you play here now what can
white do that will stop black from
catheline for at least a little while
Charlie I'm oh you wanted to play like
um let's let's uh I think that you mean
Bishop takes f2 but I can take with a
queen and then I don't think it's I
don't think you have enough for giving
up a whole piece but my question is how
does white stop black from castling
there Justin well this takes up seven
stops you from castling but the problem
is you're giving up a whole bishop and
you're only getting a pond and when you
do that you want to make sure that you
have a concrete follow up because that's
how that's a big material deficit to go
on with the game okay so you should
always look at moves like Bishop takes
f7 because sacrifice is often lead to
great combinations but only do it if you
think you have a good reason for it
Arjun Bishop h6 excellent and I'll see
how this never could have happen if you
didn't have your pawn here right Charlie
so that's why I didn't like that move
Bishop c5 and again this is this is a
bit more more advanced but it's called
holes you're making a lot of holes in
your king so instead of putting your
Bishop on c5 I would have put my Bishop
where where should we put our bishop
instead here AJ notwell h6 is possible
but it's like kind of weird because it's
not protected I don't really like
putting my bishop on a square where it's
we call this kind of a loose Bishop
Bishop g7 who said that raise your hand
but that is the right move that is what
I like because now these holes are
covered so the bad part is that the
bishop doesn't have a lot of scope but
it's worth it because now we get to
castle and our knight is protected and
whites queen is not really doing very
much and it's a good position for us
okay so this is a really important
opening line that you need to remember
don't let your opponent checkmate you
early in the game and take advantage of
it in a way that allows you to develop
quickly and castle now I'm going to go
over a very famous opening that a lot of
people play especially at the highest
levels in fact if any of you get a
chance to see some of the games in the
World Championship match between Magnus
Carlsen what type it is it's an India
very good in November yeah how do you
know all that you don't know you know
your parents told you excellent and you
know who Magnus Carlsen is going to be
playing who excellent an Indian guy
whose name begins with a vis H I love it
I'm arguing I'm not yes and you know
what city they're playing in why were
they playing tonight okay great how do
you know that oh and very good so that's
going to be an interesting match and I'm
going to tell you both of these players
play this opening so not only do you see
it a lot at the level of scholastic
chess aren't even playing in the in the
kids tournament after this okay so
you're likely to see this MOOC sorry up
your
likely to see the really low Pez which
is what we're going to look at in the in
the Scholastic math but you're also
likely to see it if you turn on your
computer and you look over the games the
World Championship that play next week I
could be wrong it could be that magnus
and magnus carlsen an anon decide to
play something totally different but
there's a very high chance that we'll
see at least one game in that match with
the move the Ray Lopez one of the most
famous openings in chess now how does
that start how does this real Oh PES
this famous opening one of the oldest -
Charlie yes how do you get how do we get
the real Oh PES Bishop to b5 excellent
why is this move so popular
anybody here first of all does anybody
here play this for white or do most of
you play Bishop c4 okay so we've got a
few hands up few hands up and what's
your name in the yellow shirt ah daddy
right okay
I'm pronouncing that right Adi okay you
play this as white what's that you also
play bishops before you switch back and
forth okay
well eat - I don't like as much it's not
as aggressive I think you should stick
Adi to one of these - how many people
play this one raise your hand
how many played this one very few okay
they're both good moves and you know I
would pick one and try to master it and
then you know you can switch around a
little bit but we're going to look a
little bit of Bishop b5 today now it's
pretty obvious why we played Bishop c4
because this pawn we can sometimes
capture or put more pressure on but
Bishop e5 what's the reason for this
move why is that a popular opening as
well Lily
there because the bishop takes the
knight in the pot then the other one
will get to excellent very very good if
we take this if we take this night off
then this pawn could become weak exactly
did you have somebody you had something
to a daddy no okay great so there's a
couple different things that black
sometimes plays in this position
sometimes they play Knight f6 right away
and sometimes they play a six in this
position now that may seem strange
because it's kind of like they're
ignoring what Lily just said right that
this night could be captured followed by
this pawn all right see what happens if
we do that so if this bishop takes a
knight how do you think blacks would
really capture right so we just took a
knight better do something about that I
Yan day right but you have to tell me
which black pawn because I got two black
pawns I can take away well b7 is one
possibility but then after we play for
instance Knight takes pawn what are you
going to do
I'm you have a way to play here but it's
not as strong as it would be if you've
taken what the other pond so even though
I like your move in in a in principle
and there's a general principle as
anybody heard that you should be
capturing towards the center anybody
heard that you guys are raising your
hand because you've heard that principle
now the reason you should capture
towards the center is the same reason
that we can't that we develop our pieces
towards the center usually if you have a
choice between captures like let me give
you an example I'll just make up an
example here like say this is a position
and there's a bishop here like this
Bishop gets out to here somehow and this
bishop takes this as a general principle
which pawn do we take away Arjun no that
leaves only one option Aida why right
well we take with this pawn because it's
capturing towards why right exactly it's
capturing 20 Center in this case would
also open the rock file which is kind of
nice but the key thing is that now we
have more control over the center and
the C and the D pawns are still
connected words if we were to take with
this guy this pawn would actually be
isolated and we'd be going towards a
side of the board which is not what we
want to do right so I like that I yawn
they played that right principle in this
position but the thing about chess is
that there's always a conflict between
these rules that you learn and the
specifics of a position every position
is different in chess
for instance actually my last class my
last class there they don't play there
they're younger than you guys the
average age is a lot younger and a lot
of just learned chess so I talked to
them about how the knight on the room is
dim and one of the parents actually
asked me about a position where I put
the knight on the rim for a really good
reason and I just explained that you
can't get too carried away with these
rules that you learn right like in this
position obviously you're happy to move
your knight to the rim and capture a
free Queen right and that
anything comes up all the time in chess
if you're winning material you're happy
to capture towards the center I mean
away from the center so that's why in
this position usually black captures
away from the center because they have a
really good plan for when the white
takes this pawn what's blacks plan here
what can white do I mean sorry black
welcome back through here that's really
good the guitar I can't remember your
name what is it again
Augusta alright looking black through
here that's really good
well no that's not the best move what
happened here basically is remember we
got black loss upon right so we got a
bishop and we want to get our pawn back
so that we can have the same amount of
stuff that our opponent has right we
call that material in the beginning of
the game you always want to try to take
off as many of your opponent's pieces as
possible as long as you're not getting
made it or anything like that
because that will help you win the game
so we're down upon we want to make it
even you I well that's it Bishop to b4
there's a reason I don't like that move
first of all you're not getting your
pawn back secondly this Bishop is really
easy to attack with a move like this
pawn here so that's not my favorite are
gen Queen to h4 is good idea trying to
attack this pawn but how would I stop
you from taking that oh wow I mean I've
got a lot of good moves here I got a lot
of good moves here but one thing that I
would I would really really want to do
here is August yeah
Knight to c3 is a really good move Oh c4
is not as good because I can take this
with check and then at least I get my
pawn back night either is a good move
another move I love in this position
Caleb okay you're talking about black
I'm talking about white now Tristan
Knight to d3 is not my favorite move
here my favorite move in this position
is something that we're always trying to
do in chess Castle yes one a castle here
because if you take this pawn off it's
extremely dangerous why is that just
want you to notice something about this
ind your king in your queen are in the
same file and that's going to be really
dangerous when we move a major piece to
where our gen rook e1 and now when you
move your queen away like say you move
your queen here notice how my work and
your king are lined up now what could
boy do Justin Knight will be a check
where would you move it to so there's a
little bit of a better move is about
Knight g6 excellent is about 96 is a
check and then this look is also hanging
see that so that's not right so that's a
how do we call that check actually in
time for Halloween I have a special name
for it
we got a booty uh D oo D right it's
called a discover check sometimes I I
tell people it's called a boo check
because you're moving one piece and
you're uncovering an attack and it's
like the kid the game that they play
with children
peekaboo right so ninety-six check
winning the rook would be very good so
that's why Queen h4 suggestion by Origen
was a good idea but it was not the best
move there's actually a better way to
try to regain our pawn here so what we
want to do is we want to use a double
attack I actually have a video on
YouTube that I gave for a kids class
maybe six months ago where I talked
about double attacks and
important they are anytime in chess you
can do two things at once
that's beautiful Fork yes fork is a
synonym for double attack so can we have
a fork care what Nona yes I think that
is thank you very good she's talking
about my book is about talking about my
book play like a girl where I have a
whole chapter on double attack no I'm
looking for a remover blackhat Forks yes
move a black that creates a fork and
wins back our pawn so it takes two
things at once we got to move your that
attacks two things at once uh D X
something without you're going to say
origin
okay so Queen B four is very good what
are the two things that attacks it wants
is well the knight in the pawn right and
we can't attack defend both of them at
once well but it doesn't attack these
things because they're protected some
kind of only counting things that are
unprotected because if we counted things
that were protected then if you're
attacking something that's protected
it's not a real attack especially if
it's a queen because we don't want to
attack something protected with a queen
because the Queen's the most powerful
piece that makes sense so if it's a
smaller piece attacking a bigger piece
those attacks count but in the case of
the Queen it doesn't relay all right
so Queen before you can hack both we
regain our pawn and we're probably going
to stop you from castling it's like if
you play here we check and you can't
cancel out a check right so that's the
whole reason that the main move in the
royal up has is to play a sex and now
wait actually plays Bishop a4 and other
two sides continue with their
development you usually see something
like b5 attacking the bishop Bishop b3
and then you see positions like this
where the petitions rather closed what
does a closed position mean in chess so
you may heard this word before a closed
position this is the kind of thing we
see happening in the Royal has a lot
this type of position the work is
usually on
you won so that we can protect you for
earlier Arjun okay well let's start with
the open okay very good in an open
position we want to develop our pieces
very quickly but what's what defines an
open position how can you tell whether
positions open or closed there's one
really important thing how do you know
this is a closed position that means
there's not a lot of open files or open
diagonals how can you tell there's one
trick to that you can tell right away AJ
well that's a clue you ask the bishop's
when the bishops don't have a lot of
scope that usually means that it's a
more closed position and that it's more
favorable for knights excellent but how
can you tell Arjun
it's more about less about pieces and
it's more about what else what creates
open files and diagonals trading what
when you trade what type of piece does
it create open files and diagonals Eli
exactly pawned when you trade pawns
it creates open position so for instance
imagine if we had all this off the board
notice how open it is and how important
it is for both sides to tax all right so
that's how you tell the difference
between an open position and a closed
position are there pawns that have been
traded and in this opening the Ray Lopez
we see there are no pawns that have been
traded in this particular type of
variation and that's why it's closed and
that's why both players are going to
play a lot of slower maneuvers instead
of the extremely rapid development that
we usually say